amazon is one of the most controversial
companies
out there but unlike most other
their controversy doesn't originate from
poor customer service
or overpriced products or bad
environmental practices
ironically a significant amount of
criticism that amazon receives
is actually that they make too much
money or more specifically
their foundation of bezos makes too much
money while their day-to-day workers are
seemingly overworked
and underpaid so how much does amazon
profit from each of our orders
anyways
[Music]
well starting off we'll be taking a look
at amazon's latest quarterly report
in order to piece together where exactly
the revenue is going
diving into their earnings over the last
several years the first thing you'll
notice
is that amazon's net income has been
significantly increasing
over the past several quarters this is
because amazon has finally gotten their
infrastructure and logistics up to a
point
where things are running smoothly for
decades amazon struggled to make their
retail business profitable
as they were sinking billions into
building warehouses buying trucks and
buying planes
in order to actually fulfill their
ambitious delivery time frames
but as these investments have started to
settle into place
amazon has been able to significantly
grow their bottom line
with that being said let's take a look
at their top line
in the first nine months of 2020 amazon
was able to pull in net product sales
of 144.859 billion dollars
and net service sales of 115.650 billion
dollars
most of their product sales do come from
amazon prime members
here's the thing not only are 65 percent
of amazon shoppers prime members
but more importantly these customers
convert at
significantly higher levels in fact
amazon prime members convert an
astounding
74 of the time while non-prime members
only convert
13 of the time 13 itself is an
awesome number considering that the
average e-commerce website conversion
rate within the us
is only 2.63 nonetheless
13 is only a fraction of 74
despite this significant difference in
conversion rates though
prime members and non-prime members
spend roughly the same amount when it
comes to each order
amazon prime members on average spend
47.72 cents per order
while non-prime members spend on average
47.25 cents
so amazon's main value when it comes to
prime members
is their order frequency as opposed to
their order amount
with all of this information we can
estimate how much of amazon's net
product sales
are from prime members if we have a
random group of
100 amazon shoppers 65 will be prime
members
and 35 will be non-prime members out of
these potential buyers
48.1 prime members will actually end up
buying
while only 4.55 non-prime members will
convert
factoring in their respective order
amounts amazon would receive
two thousand two hundred ninety five
dollars from pie members while they
would only receive 215 dollars
from non-prime members in other words 91
of amazon's retail revenue comes from
amazon prime members
as a result we'll assume that the
average customer on amazon
is indeed a prime member amazon's prime
memberships run 120 dollars per year
and the average prime member spends 1400
per year
on amazon if we spread the cost of the
membership across
all of the average members purchases we
get approximately
8.5 percent so if an average customer
were to spend
100 on amazon they're actually spending
about 108 dollars and 50 cents
and that gives them faster shipping
prime video and all of the other perks
prime offers
now that we got all of that out of the
way we can take a look at how amazon
will actually spend this revenue
amazon does provide a breakdown of where
they spend their revenue
however that also includes revenue from
aws
or amazon web services but the operating
expenses of aws
are less than 10 of amazon's overall
operating expenses
so we'll assume that the figures amazon
provides are roughly proportionally
accurate to their retail business
with that being said the first operating
expense for amazon
is cost of sales which comes in at 154
billion
this is by far their biggest expense as
the products they sell
aren't free either amazon themselves
fronted the cost of manufacturing
as is the case with amazon basics
products and their smart speakers and so
on
or amazon has to pay a proportion of
their revenue to the sellers of their
product
thus if you spend 100 on amazon you're
technically actually spending
108.50 on average and
out of that approximately 64.14
goes towards amazon actually getting the
product amazon themselves
do not profit anything from this however
the manufacturer or seller may profit
within this amount
for instance amazon may have paid the
seller 64.
but it only cost the seller 40 to get it
from the manufacturer
and it may have only cost the
manufacturer 20 to make the product
meaning that each the seller and the
manufacturer pocket 20
but amazon doesn't get anything
hopefully
that made sense anyways moving on
amazon spent 40.043 billion on
fulfillment
this category is self-explanatory this
amount went towards warehouse workers
planes trucks fuel and everything else
required in delivering your purchase
on your 100 purchase about 16.68
will go towards logistics next up we
have technology and content
which runs 30.691 billion
this is the amount amazon actually has
to pay the providers
for their content most amazon prime
members mainly only use the delivery
benefits
and might check out prime video here and
there but
there are a lot of other perks that most
never use like amazon music prime
prime gaming amazon photos and many more
for the people who do take advantage of
these services though
amazon has to of course play the
creators of the content
whether that be the director of the
movie the artist of a song
or a twitch streamer they might also
need to spend money on cloud storage
space
if you decide to back up your photos
with amazon photos
thus most of this amount goes towards
making the services that come along with
amazon prime
possible on your 100 order
this comes out to roughly 12 dollars and
78 cents
moving forward we have marketing
expenses which cost 14.605 billion
for amazon this includes both direct and
indirect marketing strategies
as for direct we of course have the
regular advertisements and promotional
material
that we are all familiar with their
indirect marketing efforts however
are much more subtle for instance they
have to pay referral fees to affiliate
marketers
and they have to pay for sponsorships
sponsored products
anyways in relation to the 100 order
only about six dollars and eight cents
goes towards marketing
finally we have two more straightforward
expenditures which are general and
administrative
as well as miscellaneous expenses
general and administrative costs come
out to 4.7 billion dollars
while miscellaneous expenses only come
out to 421 million
as a proportion of 100 order general and
administrative is approximately 1.95
cents
and miscellaneous is only 17.5 cents
adding all of these together we get a
total of 101.81 cents
meaning that every time you buy
something on amazon they actually spend
more than you
in order to actually deliver everything
they promise the amazon prime revenue
and other services revenue of course
make up for this though
leaving amazon in the green factoring in
this revenue
amazon profits 6.69 cents for every 100
you spend on amazon if we also add in
their interest income
and subtract taxes their net income per
100 dollars
is about 5.88 however
that number is a bit inflated by their
high margin amazon web services business
if we strictly take a look at their
retail business by region
though we don't get a breakdown of how
exactly amazon spends their revenue
they do reveal how much they make at the
end of the day in north america
amazon has a total operating income of
5.704 billion
out of 160.936 billion in net sales
this would mean that amazon's operating
income within the us
per 100 is actually a little bit lower
at about 3.85
meanwhile amazon essentially makes no
money abroad
their operating income internationally
is only 355 million
out of 66.945 billion in net sales
the average international customer
likely doesn't have a prime membership
thus for every 100 they spend amazon
only gets
100 and out of that revenue amazon will
profit a mere 53 cents
but then how is jeff bezos making tens
of billions
every single year the answer lies within
this large stake in amazon
as of july 2020 jeff bezos owned 55.5
million shares of amazon
or an 11.1 stake in the company
and taking a look at amazon stock graph
over the past decade
it's no wonder why he's made so much
money in fact
jeff bezos only makes a modest eighty
one thousand eight hundred forty dollars
a year
as a salary and receives no stock
compensation
the other 1.6 million you see here is
spent on security measures for jeff
bezos
so his gains can be explained by stake
in amazon
but why are investors buying up stock of
a company with such bigger profit
margins
well amazon is valued as a growth
company and
investors have been buying the stock of
the company based on future growth
and profitability here's the thing
amazon's p e ratio
is about 90 today this means that if
amazon were to stop growing and stop
increasing their profit margins
it would take you over 90 years to make
back your invested money at their
current margins
so jeff bezos is not making billions
based on amazon's profits
today but rather he's making billions on
the hope that amazon will one day be
extremely profitable
and lucrative fortunately for jeff bezos
and amazon investors
considering amazon's trend over the past
several years this does seem to be the
case
did you guys realize that amazon barely
makes any money comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys enjoyed
this rough estimate of how exactly your
money is spent by amazon
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one